[Music]
the time has finally come for a new
Fallout game like previous entries
fallout 76 is a massive game filled to
the brim with RPG systems and mechanical
details many of which aren't explained
in detail add that on top of a new
multiplayer functionality and is more
than likely that you've got some
questions that need answers fortunately
we're here to help with our collective
knowledge having each play the game for
a couple dozen hours and this feature
will go over tips you should know about
the game survival and progression
systems as well as call out important
details to keep in the forefront of your
mind as you play once you leave vault 76
you are free to go anywhere you want but
don't let that freedom go to your head
as you most definitely lack the
resources needed to survive if you're
not careful you'll likely end up
somewhere high leveled and dangerous We
strongly recommend at least doing the
first couple of quests in the main story
which act as an extended tutorial and
also provide you with a ton of important
supplies and blueprints the story
missions in the overseers camp the town
of flatwoods and the Morgantown Airport
teach you about workbenches diseases and
how your camp works you'll also gain a
ton of basic weapons ammo aid supplies
recipes and plans for building after
Morgantown you'll be in much better
shape to start exploring freely keep in
mind that the main story is in general a
great way to get new stuff and learn the
game so it's a good idea to hop back in
and do it every once in a while the camp
is a new feature in fallout 76 that acts
as your own personal base that you can
use to rest repair equipment and
eventually build your own home
because it's technically a camp that
means you can move it to anywhere you
want on the map for a small fee of
course but don't fret as stuff you've
already crafted is stored and can be
replaced at no cost you only have to
worry about building something like a
workbench once traveling to your camp is
always free so try to place it
strategically that means putting it near
resources existing crafting benches and
water until you have unlocked crafting
stations and water purifiers to do the
work for you even if you aren't
interested in building up your camp it's
worth creating a basic one that has all
the stuff you need like a cooking
station work benches and a stash it's
also worth noting that you can't just
set up your camp anywhere you please it
needs to be in a location that isn't
named in addition if you want to
preserve your stuff on the elements make
sure you store your stuff in your stash
like previous follow games your
characters inventory limit is going to
be a constant obstacle because when
you're carrying too much stuff your
action points are sapped just for moving
around compared to past games we just
move incredibly slow because of this
your stash at home base is one of your
most valuable assets always have a stash
in your camp and use it to store stuff
to make space for yourself only you can
access your stash so anything you place
in there is safe from the hands of
unfriendly players you'll notice other
stash boxes throughout the world and in
other people's camps but using them will
only access your stash and not anybody
else's if you're too far away from your
camp and need to know where to look for
a stash they'll usually be one at a
train station or Red Rocket always throw
whatever junk you've picked up into your
stash there's actually a command that
instantly offloads all of your junk in
the stash menu once all your junk is in
your stash you have access to all of it
at any workbench for crafting so you
don't need to worry about carrying it
around everywhere you go do keep in mind
that the stash does have an item limit
it's not possible to build a second one
so eventually you're gonna have to start
getting rid of stuff you can't put off
spring cleaning
not even in Fallout 76 weapons and armor
conditions return for Fallout 76 after
having been absent from Fallout 4
however unlike fallout 3 and new Vegas
where you could just use another armor
or weapon of the same type to improve
the first condition you need specific
junk to repair your gear in fallout 76
much like how you upgrade mods if you're
missing materials you
can tag them for search just like in
fallout 4 to help you find what you need
when scavenging well-armored takes a
little time to bus
weapons can degrade rather quickly so
make sure to keep an eye on them
least they break in the middle of combat
one of the newest additions to fallout
seventy-six are diseases and they can
really harm you if you're not careful
you can get them from pretty much
anything the obvious comes from enemies
labelled as disease such as a diseased
radroach which can easily infect you by
touching you when you see an enemy
marked as diseased it's always best to
shoot them from a distance you wouldn't
think it but beds have a high chance of
giving you disease specifically any
bedding that's not raised off the ground
you can also catch diseases from eating
rotten or raw food swimming in water or
even just walking in certain areas that
contain airborne diseases waterborne
diseases can be avoided by wearing
certain equipment like hazmat or
spacesuits and airborne diseases can be
avoided by wearing gas masks like the
fire breather helmet if you're
unfortunate enough to catch a disease
your options are to either wait it out
or cure it with medicine waiting for
disease to go away on its own takes
anywhere from 30 minutes to an hour
depending on the disease hearing a
disease is obviously the preferred
method but pure disease which is what
the item is called can be tough to find
you can craft it a chorus but you got to
make sure you have materials for that
alternatively if you're in a real pinch
you can set up your camp and just wait
to die and respawn which will cure your
disease power armor is high level
equipment that comes in handy later on
but in your early runnings you'll come
across plenty of power armor jassi's out
in the world but they'll only have a few
pieces of armor on them these pieces are
usually around either level 25 or level
40 so you can't even use them most of
the time but don't ignore these just
because they're at a low level as you
can still take advantage of them remove
all of the armor pieces attached to the
power armor and if you have the space
bring it back with you to store in your
stash after that hop into the power
armor chassis which even without any
armor plates attached still gives you a
defense bonus and boost to your carrying
capacity it's worth noting that once you
hop into a power armor chassis it's
yours which means you can store in your
inventory or place it in your stash
taking the time to scavenge power armor
pieces early on will put you in a better
place when you reach the appropriate
level to actually use fully decked out
power armor crafting is an important
part of the fallout experience after all
if you're gonna survive out in the
wasteland you need to leverage all that
useless junk you grab into functional
items as explore you will find new
planes and recipes that will expand your
repertoire for craftable items now you
may think these will get added to the
workbench recipe list upon picking them
up but you'd be mistaken to unlock them
in your crafting list simply pull them
up in your pip-boy and confirm them in
the notes section of your inventory
follow 76 is a multiplayer game so
interacting with other people is a major
component but you must be wondering
what's possible with other people first
off there is in-game voice chat that's
area based letting you hear people close
by direct communication is a useful tool
for asking players if they want to trade
or help you out if you don't want to
hear other players you can always turn
it off in the audio settings and it's
still possible to communicate with
visual emotes trading with other players
is as simple as walking up to them and
pressing a button you get a full look at
someone's inventory and can request
specific items you're interested in of
course there's also PvP you can't attack
or be attacked by other players until
you reach level 5 which is meant to
prevent spawn camping outside vault 76
and killing all the newcomers once you
can attack other is you'll notice that
when you first start shooting players
you'll actually be inflicting a reduced
amount of damage again this is meant to
prevent random people from just killing
you or from you killing them if the
other player attacks back the two of you
will have officially engaged in combat
with the damage safety turned off while
it's difficult it is possible to kill a
player who isn't fighting back but doing
so is considered murder that puts a
bounty on your head and it replaces the
icon on the map with a bright shiny red
star letting everyone know where you are
any player can then murder you and be
rewarded with a bounty of cats which
comes out of your personal supply you'll
get some rewards from the bodies of dead
players but looting them isn't going to
score you their armor or weapons instead
you will only get their junk and
crafting supplies while this may not
seem like much scoring a large supply of
junk can be a nice boost for you while
losing a lot of junk you just spent the
last
collecting can be pretty devastating
luckily your dead body will be marked on
the map so you can recover your stuff
regardless of what killed you when an
encounter stops being fun and games you
can block a player by finding them in
the social menu and then flagging them
alright we covered a lot of the big
stuff but there's a lot of smaller stuff
packed into this game that's worth being
mindful from here's some tips that we
thought were pretty important but not
enough to warrant their own section
holotapes still play when you enter a
loading screen but you no longer hear
them so if you have a tape playing wait
before you leave or enter a building or
fast travel until you're done listening
to it always carry a hazmat suit with
you there are tons of areas of heavy
radiation that can quickly kill you if
you spend time there so a hazmat suit is
essential that and they can also prevent
airborne and waterborne diseases if you
find an instrument take 30 seconds to
play it and receive the well-tuned
status which grants do a bonus 25% ap
regeneration for one hour the warrant if
you murder someone while in a party your
teammates can start attacking you right
away you won't be able to attack them
however because you're on the same team
while it requires further research on
our end you could technically use this
to gain the murder system use a tinker's
workbench to bulk your materials which
will condense them and reduce the weight
bring up more space in your stash if
your meat veggies or fruit spoiled don't
eat it but also don't throw it away you
can convert them into fertilizer sleep
at the start of every play session until
you get the well rested icon being well
rested means you get a bonus to xp for a
short while you can swap the pip-boy
between two viewing modes the standard
one takes up your entire view but the
alternate version lets you see what's
around you while navigating menus while
building the camp many objects in the
world block larger saved bases from
being placed
fortunately you only really need one
point of contact and then you can float
your entire base in a single set of
stairs even if you don't like vats it's
still very good for quick headshots with
bolt-action rifles finally this is a PC
specific tip remap the grenade button if
you plan on capturing using shadow play
it's currently set to you left Alt +
trying to start and stop shadow play
will have you accidentally throw a
grenade also it's just kind of an
awkward key to put the melee grenade on
in the first place
those were all our tips for fall at 76
it can be a confusing game so hopefully
these tips helps you guys out if you
have any tips that we missed or useful
information please put it down in the
comments below and hey if there's enough
maybe we'll make another one of these
tips videos have a great day
you